les magasins s'en émeut nous compte
multiplier par cinq le nombre d'artisans
d'ici dont les produits seront offerts
sur sa plateforme en ligne fabrique 1840
pieters a menacé le président et
directeur général du magasin simons
bonsoir monsieur symons bonfoh la
première question toute simple comment
comment allez-vous dans le contexte
actuel comment va votre entreprise
moi personnellement j'ai des bonnes
journées des mauvaises journées comme
tout le monde j'imagine mais on se
débrouille tout le monde est en santé
pour l'entreprise c'est des moments
c est fébrile c'est pas le bon mais
assez intense depuis six semaines
effectivement je pense pour tous les
commerces beaucoup d'entreprises se dit
max thème main tendue existentielle même
j'aime vous perdez beaucoup d'argent des
milliers des millions de dollars mais
oui on a assez de garder en place
incertaine encore dans l'entreprise mais
les pertes sont énormes chaque semaine
ne vous cacherai pas que dalle dans les
millions donc entre temps on a quand
même notre commerce électronique et ce
au sunside pluie s'est pas assez pour
compenser sur les coûts reliés ou
fermeture des médias
mais est-ce que l' annonce la
réouverture vous rassure vous vous
prévoir on prévoit rouvrir le 19 mai
chez vous mais on a annoncé quand même
le gouvernement du québec à partir du 4
mai pourquoi vous vous attendez le 19
bon c'était une annonce qui était plat
semaine passée au nous on était déjà en
train de planifier la réouverture mais
c'est assez complexe c'est pas comme un
interrupteur fermer les magasins c'était
une affaire le plus de ce que j'ai fait
mes regrets ouvrir les magasins c'est
même plus c'est dans cette question
d'assurer tous les procédés
l'équipement en place dans tous nos
magasins pour assurer la sécurité de nos
nos employés l'équipe de vente et polis
client br / et c'est beaucoup de
procédures à mettre en place pour
s'assurer que tout est mieux j'ai fait
un choix évidemment géante à rouvrir
comme tout le monde mais mieux le marché
tranquillement à venir réfléchir et de
courir et se tromper vous avez bien sûr
poursuivi comme d'autres entreprises vos
activités en ligne de vente en ligne qui
vous avez aussi une plateforme de vente
de produits de fabricants qu'ils aient
quoi canadien des artisans du si ça
marche bien en ce moment
oui le commerce électronique en général
était fortement hausse mais ce qui
m'encourage et le plus c'était vraiment
la performance de notre plateforme pour
artisans créateurs de québec du québec
qui s'appelle fabrique 1840
c'est une plate forme dans laquelle on a
investi 4 5 1 et avec la sensibilisation
à l'achat local et leur courage mr des
petits artisans onu une croissance
exponentielle cette idée c'est un des
aspects du confinement le plus positif
joué que y'avait une sensibilisation et
une action vers le support des artisans
locaux et ça m'a beaucoup encouragé et
j'ai senti c'était le tad d'agrandir
cette communauté que cette plateforme
qui a une des artisans se numériser et
se référant si sûr sur le web
est ce que ça vous amène vous à vous
tourner davantage vers des artisans des
fournisseurs d'ici peut-être un peu
moins vers des fournisseurs de
l'extérieur
certainement parce que premièrement
c'est le coteau et les artisans
toujours privilège de côtoyer cette
créativité là ça nous amène
insensibilité une appréciation pour le
produit et on sent généralement de mieux
pour un mouvement vouloir voulant
favoriser les artisans et des
manufactures locale donc oui c'est vrai
c'est je pense qu'on a beaucoup à offrir
aux artisans mais je m'en sors un poste
on a beaucoup à retirer à recevoir aussi
point de vue d'appréciation à et de
créativité
vous vous avez quoi c'est une centaine
d'artisans en ce moment si vous voulez
monter à 500 comment vous allez y
arriver mais on va arriver en train de
les recruter
les contacts et de faire comme avec le
plate forme je pense que il ya beaucoup
de discussions autour de la difficulté à
assas l'entrée d'un monde numérique
mais c'est pas le seul défi c'est plutôt
la référence main c'est facile d'être
sur le web mais c'est pas facile de ceux
de faire l'addition de clients sur le
web avec nos compétences en commerce
électronique avec 60 millions de
visiteurs uniques qui annuellement
seule sa propre solution complète non
seulement ou numérisation mais au
référencement sur le web est un explosif
au caesars alors que je pense qui peut
être très bénéfique
un artisan un créateur qui nous
regardent ce soir là qui vous regardent
en fait il fait quoi
il me rejoigne il peut contacter cécile
le bras causé branco ap 100 points c est
si l'intérêt on serait content de lui
expliquer comment le plateforme
fonctionne
comment propose de l'intégrer dans la
plateforme et le ce pacte ils vont
conseiller sur pays j'espère qu'ils vont
aimer la communauté puis qu'est ce que
ça peut amener je pense de la voir des
courriels avec la réouverture des
magasins est ce que vous allez rappeler
tous vos travailleurs en étant obligés
de commencer processus je pense qu'on
est faux que c'est sûr qu'il est
normalement extérieur extrêmement sûre
on
après tout le monde mais c'est sûr qu'on
va ouvrir avec des heures le 18 et
graduellement
ça serait une processus sortie mona
passage parce que tous les procédures
vont être changés puis il faut savoir
regarder l'achalandage se serait pas un
retour normal pour moi ce serait quelque
chose de graduelle donc nous allons
suivre ce de jour en jour et est ce que
vous craignez que des travailleurs qui
ne veulent pas revenir parce que des
prestations en ce moment oui ça
m'inquiète un peu évidemment le magasin
ne peut pas l'ouvrir tout seul je pense
que il ya un moment il faut qu'on roule
les manches comprend les précautions
nécessaires
c'est ce matin j'ai eu une discussion
avec mes enfants sur le travail puis la
question c'est pour une question
d'argent simplement c'est aussi une
question de satisfaction de plaisir de
servir les oddh de valeur et
d'apprentissage donc écouter ça
m'inquiète un peu parce qu'évidemment on
est une équipe ce que tout le monde pour
être capable d ouvrir mais j'ai
confiance pyj j'espère que j'y que j'ai
confiance que les gens vont vouloir
tenir et
et à cette question là parce que c'est
uniquement une question pérennité pour
beaucoup d'entreprises à québec et il
faut un rôle tout le monde est moche ou
pour vous et pour ça et même sur une
question de pérennité qu'un train
absolument je vous cache au pot tout le
monde à leurs difficultés mais c'était
c'est une situation extrêmement complexe
wimbee nos fournisseurs aux inventaires
me dérange c'est pour nous c'est arrivé
au pire moment
on venait deux ans venait de compléter
un investissement important dans la
logistique que robotique pour desservir
notre commerce électronique
mais mon quatre semaines avant d'ouvrir
les ligues programmant les ingénieurs
sont toutes retournées chez zueras
d'etats-unis ailleurs au canada
alors je vous souhaite bonne chance
monsieur ça et mende merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
merci nous et merci bien